GRAINY JOINING US TONIGHT ON
HANNITY, WE APPRECIATE IT.
DESPITE THE MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENC
AGAINST SUSSMAN, PROSECUTORS
FACE AN UPHILL BATTLE IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE CLINTON DONORS I
THE JURY POOL.
HERE NOW WITH MORE IS GEORGE
WASHINGTON LAW PROFESSOR
JONATHAN TURLEY GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US PROFESSOR
, YOU HAVE WRITTEN
ABOUT THIS, I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS ON THIS, BUT WHAT
IS IT, THREE OF THE JURORS ARE
ACTUALLY CLINTON DONORS?
WHY ARE THEY SITTING IN THE JUR
POOL?
>> IT'S A BIZARRE TWIST, BUT
WHEN WE GARY GUARANTEE YOU JURY
OF YOUR PEERS, WE DON'T MEET IF
YOU ARE A CLINTON PERSON YOU
WILL BE TRIED BY OTHER CLINTON
PEOPLE.
YOU FEEL LIKE JOHN DURHAM MIGHT
TAKE AWAY THE LESSONS THAT THAT
IS THE CASE IN DC.
90 PERCENT OF PEOPLE VOTED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON IN DC.
SO THE JURY POOL IS GOING TO BE
NATURALLY HEAVILY WEIGHTED IN
THAT DIRECTION PRIDE THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A SUPPORTER
IN A DONOR.
WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE THAT
INDICATED THEY ARE CLINTON
DONORS.
WE ALSO HAVE ANOTHER PERSON WHO
SAID THAT SHE IS A DONOR TO AOC
AND HAD TO BE SORT OF PROBED AN
PRODDED I SHOULD SAY TO SAY THA
SHE WAS GOING TO BE ACTUALLY
IMPARTIAL.
THESE PEOPLE VERY WELL COULD BE
IMPARTIAL AND FAIR.
CERTAINLY CLINTON'S PORTERS CAN
BE FAIR AND IMPARTIAL JURORS.
IT WHEN YOU HAVE DONORS ON THE
JURIES IT WHEEZES WORLD ROLE
CONCERNS.
THERE IS ALSO A JUROR WHOSE
DAUGHTER PLAYS ON A TEAM WITH
SUSSMAN'S DAUGHTER, AND THE
JUDGE SAID I'M GOING TO LET THA
GO THROUGH AS WELL.
FOR JOHN DURHAM, I THINK THE
IMPRESSION THAT SHORT OF HAVING
CHELSEA CLINTON ON THE JURY, I
COULDN'T BE DOING MUCH WORSE IN
TERMS OF A JURY POOL.
HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT, I DON'
MEAN TO SUGGEST THAT THESE
JURORS ARE GOING TO BE BIASED,
THEY VERY WELL COULD BE
IMPARTIAL, JURORS THINK TAKE
THINGS VERY SERIOUSLY.
WHAT'S CLEAR IS THE EVIDENCE
AGAINST SUSSMAN'S OVERWHELMING,
I MEAN SUSSMAN'S TEXT TO BAKER
STATES VERY CLEARLY I AM NOT
REPRESENTING ANY CLIENT AND THE
PROSECUTORS HAVE SAID HE WAS,
AND HE WAS BUILDING THAT TIME T
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE THIS
BOMBSHELL OF HIM SAYING THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PERSONALLY
GREENLIGHTED THIS EFFORT, THESE
JUROR CONNECTIONS BECOME MORE O
A CONCERN.
THEY CERTAINLY BECOME MORE
MAGNIFIED BECAUSE ONE OF THE
JURORS WAS TOLD BY A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, DON'T WORRY, LORI
CLINTON AND DONALD TRUMP ARE NO
ON TRIAL HERE BRIGHT AND THE
JURY SAID OKAY, THEN I REALLY
THINK I CAN BE IMPARTIAL.
AS OF FRIDAY, HILLARY CLINTON
WAS VERY MUCH PART OF THE
TESTIMONY.
YOU'VE ALSO COMMENTED ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE WAY
GENERAL FLYNN WAS DEALT WITH AN
THE WAY THAT THIS PROSECUTION I
GOING GREAT EXPLAINED TO US THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
BECAUSE THE JUDGE IS MAKING VER
DIFFERENT RULINGS.
>> AS YOU RECALL, WE HAD A
PERFECTLY BIZARRE SITUATION WIT
LYNN.
JUDGE EMMET SULLIVAN IN ONE
HEARING ACCUSED HIM BASICALLY
TREASON USING THE FLAG AND THE
COURTROOM IS A PROP AND,
SULLIVAN SEEMED TO REMOVE ANY
OBSTACLE FROM THE PATH OF
PROSECUTORS.
JUDGE COOPER HAS REALLY BEEN
TOUGH ON THE PROSECUTION.
HE HAS NARROWED THE SCOPE OF
EVIDENCE AND OF QUESTIONING.
HE HAS MADE A NUMBER OF RULINGS
THAT THE PROSECUTORS HAVE VERY
MUCH OBJECTED TO, AND IT SORT O
LIKE AN OBSTACLE COURSE FOR JOH
DURHAM IN THAT SENSE.
HE HAS GOT A TOUGH JURY IN A
VERY TOUGH JUDGE.
THIS IS IN THE SAME COURTROOM,
THE SAME COURTHOUSE I SHOULD SA
IN DC.
I THINK PEOPLE LOOK AT THOSE TW
TRIALS AND THEY SAY THIS IS A
REALLY STRIKING AND VERY FAIRLY
GLARING DIFFERENCE, BUT IT'S TH
SAME CHARGE ABOUT LYING TO
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS, BUT YOU
COULDN'T HAVE A GREATER
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE
OPTICS IN IN TERMS OF THESE
ORDERS.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, AND
YOU ARE ANALYZING, THE JURY POOL
, IT'S IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
DO PROSECUTORS MAKE THE MISTAKE
OF OVER COMPLICATING IT BECAUSE
IT'S A SIMPLE ONE CHARGE CASE
YOUR.
>> THAT IS TRUE, ALTHOUGH IT IS
FASCINATING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE COURTROOM BECAUSE THE
DEFENSE HAD ONE IN NARROWING TH
CASE.
COOPER GIVE THEM CRITICAL
RULINGS AND TOLD DURHAM HE
COULDN'T BRING IN THE BROADER
CONTEXT OF THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND ALSO THE SPECIFIC DATA THAT
WAS GENERATED.
TO LEAVE WHEN THOSE FIGHTS AND
THEN THEY DECIDED TO PUT HIM ON
THE STAND.
HE BECAME JOHNNY THE HUMAN TORC
ON THE STAND.
ALL OF US HAVE HAD BAD
EXPERIENCES IN COURT, BUT IF YO
WERE COMPARED TO THAT, HILLARY
CLINTON, THERE IS A GENERAL RUL
IN WASHINGTON THAT THOU SHALL
NOT NAME HILLARY CLINTON IN AN
SCANDAL IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
THIS THING REALLY VIOLATED THAT
COMMANDMENT IN DC.
KEEP IN MIND, THE RESEARCHERS
WHO PUT TOGETHER THIS MATERIAL
SAID THAT THEY DIDN'T THINK IT
WOULD STAND UP TO SCRUTINY.
AND THEN HILLARY WAS TOLD WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING CLEAR HERE.
AND SHE GREENLIGHTED IT PRIDE
THEY GAVE IT TO SLEEP.
AND SLATE RAN WITH THAT PART
THAN WE SEE THIS FAMILIAR
PATTERN CARD THEY GET FRIENDLY
MEDIA TO RUN IT, AND THEN THEY
RESPONDED THAT THEY HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT.
SO THEY THEN HAVE JAKE SULLIVAN
AND HILLARY CLINTON TWEETING OUT
, LOOK AT WHAT SLATE JUST
REPORTED.
UNDER THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE
ASSOCIATES PUSHING THESE CLAIMS
AND THE FBI.
IT IS THE SAME PATTERN FOR BOTH
THE STEEL DOSSIER IN THE ALPHA
ALPHA BANK SCANDAL.
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT, SLATE
COMES UP WITH IT AND THEY ALL
REPORTED AND REGURGITATE IT,
SUDDENLY YOU HAVE A CAMPAIGN
ATTORNEY IN A FEDERAL COURTHOUS
CHARGED WITH A CRIME, AND HE'S
TALKING ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON
AND THE MEDIA ARE ABSOLUTELY
NOWHERE IN REPORTING WE W